new unreleased music from the late
rapper Mac Miller has surfaced before
his death last year at the age of 26
Miller reportedly recorded tons of music
some of which was never released
recently a fully unreleased track called
Benji the dog hit the internet check it
out yeah and told me don't make a
promise you can't keep all the drugs in
your system you can't sleep how many
times you had to buy Plan B you never
back home to meet your family
dream about ever since my mom told me
that she named me out always smoke away
cousin trouble never cleaning house God
so soon you guys but his legacy lives on
music Kara's recently announced their
Mac Miller Legacy Fund via Twitter
saying quote we are proud to announce
the establishment of the music cares at
Mac Miller Legacy Fund which will help
music people age 27 and under who are
struggling with substance abuse the Mac
Miller fund was established by the late
rappers family after his death and the
organization will run under the
Recording Academy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]